[Music]
at the moment actually I'm with my three
collaborators that we think we're making
real progress in just within classical
physics understanding why the past is so
different from the present and the
future because this is the great mystery
of the growth of entropy which came with
the discovery of the laws of
thermodynamics in a in the 1850s so all
the known laws of nature work equally
well in the two directions of time then
why are all the processes we observe in
the universe all going in the same
direction we are all getting older in
the same direction you just like me and
all the stars are we never meet anyone
getting younger where is this colossal
asymmetry in time come from if it's not
in the fundamental laws so seven years
ago to make a concession to time I an
idea occurred to me which actually I
happen to know about a rather important
result in discovered in Newton's theory
of gravity in 1772 this led me to the
idea that the Big Bang so if we pretend
there is a timeline of the universe
which by which I mean just each
individual now what it's like like the
silver moon we suppose you have a long
infinite timeline of the universe and I
would say that the Big Bang is if you
like in the middle and we are on one
side and our time is going that way
and then there's another universe or the
other half of the whole timeline where
time is going that way now people who
were on that side would find that time
is going forward in exactly the same way
as we find it on this side it's all very
chaotic at the Big Bang there's no
structure there so we can't see through
the Big Bang to the other side and they
can't see through to us but that
restores the overall symmetry so the
overall symmetry of the whole universe
reflects the underlying law which is
symmetric in both ways but on the two
sides the direction of experienced
time is opposite so that's quite a
simple neat thing so I call this the
Janus point or Janus point that the Big
Bang half of of course after the Roman
god who looks in two opposite directions
of time at once and I'm writing a book
about this with the title is the Janus
point and a new theory of times arrows
and the Big Bang I hope I will get it
finished I'm working away ah fairly
recently had my 82nd birthday so I
better get it finished
I'm constant now fairly recently back in
February actually but it's a nice simple
idea and several quite interesting
things fit into this idea quite nicely
so and what is the main the main
challenges with this what what do you
see or foresee is the main challenges
that you'll have to tackle and recently
well first of all first of all to show
that this is that this model is based on
Newton's theory of gravity and quite a
big challenge is to show that it will
also work with Einstein's theory of
gravity now we've made it my
collaborators made a first step in that
and they've showed that in some senses
there are conditions in which you can go
through the Big Bang in general
relativity and not only in the a the
comparable situation in Newton's theory
then there would be more detailed work
to be done but the real challenge would
be to make this quantum mechanical to
unify quantum mechanics with this and
we've got ideas about this but people
have been trying for 6070 years to unify
corner mechanics with Einstein's theory
of gravity and they to be frankly
haven't got terribly far or despite them
the claims that may then like might like
to make so that's it there but one thing
we do think is that we concentrate on
what we say the shape of the universe in
any instant so if you have a triangle it
has
a panda sighs but I think you'll agree
that the shape is much more important
than the size because if I hold up a an
equilateral triangle in front of your
eyes and move it backwards and forwards
the the shape doesn't change but the
size does so you would say there's a
question mark over the size whether it's
fundamental now if you can if that
triangle is the whole universe you'd
need a ruler outside that triangle to
measure its size but if the universe is
everything that doesn't make sense
so we've developed something we call
shape dynamics to describe the whole
universe and we think that it might be
possible in that framework to unify
quantum mechanics with gravity with
Einstein's theory of gravity because
it's taking away something that
shouldn't be there and in fact all of
the sofas really all of the existing
approaches to quantum gravity in some
way or other are bringing in an external
scale which I don't think should be
there or at least there's a there's a
question mark over it and possibly a big
one so that's our hope but it's better
to be getting on with in the meanwhile
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you